[Music] Hello friends you are about to see a
video of a man named Carl Sandburg born in 1878
and he has quite a fascinating story to tell you
about witnessing a political rally in October of
1884. this was a few weeks before the election
that made Grover Cleveland the 22nd president of
the United States now some of you may have heard
of Carl Sandburg before he was a well-known poet
and biographer in the first half of the 20th
century and he lived in a small town called
Galesburg Illinois which is where the political
rally that he speaks of took place at that time
in the 1880s Illinois was predominantly Republican
and so you'll hear Mr Sandburg describe how the
crowd at the rally was mostly chanting for a man
named James G Blaine the Republican nominee for
the presidency at the time the 1884 presidential
election was highly contentious and marked by
strong hostility toward both candidates Cleveland
faced accusations of fathering an illegitimate
child while James G Blaine received backlash
over the Mulligan letters documents indicating
that he had accepted a bribe from the Union
Pacific Railroad despite these controversies
Cleveland would ascend to the presidency thanks
to a narrow win in his home state of New York by
just 1149 votes and here is a map of the final
election results for that year where President
Cleveland proved victorious in all the South and
most of the East whereas Mr Blaine was heavily
favored in the west and Midwest and so now let
us walk through the doors of time and listen
to Mr Sandburg's amazing recollection
of that night back in October of 1884.
What was it like growing up in Central
Illinois before there were any automobiles?
Well one thing a man thinks of first
of all is horses horses everywhere horses
and a man can think of how politics then was about
the same as now just as much Shenanigans as ever
I was six years old in October of 1884 when
my father took me downtown to see a republican
torchlight procession this is in Galesburg yes
hundreds of Republicans each one with a lighted
torch on his shoulder and a flambo core pipes long
pipes that blow and there would be three four feet
of fire up there a kind of a big fire flower
all at once 16 of them shooting up in the air
it was a wonder to my boy eyes and they
would march sometimes "Blaine, Blaine, James G. Blaine!"
my father had told me that was the candidate
of the Republican Party but while they
were marching every once in a while they would
come from a sidewalk a,  "Hurrah for Cleveland!"
and then from the procession there would come
"And a rope to hang him!" and you know I was a
nice little six-year-old Republican I had never
seen a hanging I didn't know what hanging was
like but if the Republicans were for it I
was like my father I was a Republican and I
was for the hanging of Grover Cleveland but a
few weeks passed and, the country elected Grover
Cleveland instead of hanging him they elected him
President of the United States and he appoints
for a postmaster in Galesburg a neighbor of
ours only two weeks only two blocks away yeah
an Irishman named Billy tuik politics was as
full of changes and surprises then as it is now
thank you
[Music]